بارد ليس فقط فرنانديز الارجنتيني وماكرون
فرنسي ولكن بوتين اعتقد الروسيزن فيشاهد
المباراه فهنا مشجعات من من روسيا اتينا
خصيصا اتينا خصيصا الى الدوحه لتسجيع
المنتخب الارجنتيني وسوق واقف منذ يوم بعد
الظهر امس لم يتوقف 35000 مشجع للمنتخب
الارجنتيني وصلوا لتحميس وتشيع المشجعين
ان يذهبوا الى استاذ لوسيل الساعه السادسه
بتوقيت الدوحه يعني بعد اقل من اربع ساعات
لمتابعه المباراه وترجيع منتخبهم ميسي
ميسي
اه ما في سيكورت ارجنتينا اند ماروكو
يشجعون المنتخب الارجنتيني والمغربي ولذلك
اتو قبل يومين لمتابعه وتحميس وترجيع
المنتخب المغربي يوم امس اند وتباوت يونج
العربي
يرجعون المنتخب الارجنتيني ماذا ستفعل
جانتي
هي تشجع المنتخب الارجنتيني لانها لانها
لديها الكثير الصديقات او الاصدقاء الذين
يشجعون هذا المنتخب والكثير كذلك من
اصدقائي يشجعون المنتخب الفرنسي طبعا راح
تكون حماسيه اكيد يا خالد المباراه خصوصا
عندما تكون لاحظت في استاد عندما تكون
الفتيات جميلات هذا يشجع على استقطاب
الكثير من يعني الفتيات احيانا يقود
المشجعين كلما هتفت فتاه كلما اربع شباب
هتفهم خلف بان تكون المباراه
ههه
اموت وابعثيها ههه
هي ابتسامه صباحيه جميله او زهريه صارت
بتوقيت الرياض والدوحه ولكن راح تكون
الابتسامات اقوى هناك في ستاديوم سنكون
معكم خالد في النشره المقبله الرابعه ان
شاء الله وستكون جماهير كبيره للمنتخبين
الفرنسي ولا والارجنتيني ولكن
الارجنتينيين كما قلت قبل قليل 35000 مشجع
هنا في الدوحه والجميع انضارهم الى شمال
الدوحه الى لوسيل وكذلك الفرنسيون الذين
اتوا بكميات اقل يعني يوجد تقريبا 6,000
فرنسي ولكن الحماس الديوك الفرنسيه مستعده
كذلك
هذه المباراه همم
كل التوفيق للمنتخبين
لكن ان شاء الله يتوفق ميسي والمنتخب
الارجنتيني شكرا لك منفد العربيه من
الدوحه لقيت مزال